il ya une question que tout le monde se
pose en ce moment
quand est ce qu'on va pouvoir reprendre
une vie normale kapuku à payer des tests
rapides sont en développement en ce
moment nous apporter des indices
précieux on va faire des études
psychologiques qu'ils vont être capables
d'identifier quelle est la proportion de
gens au québec qui est atteinte pour
savoir à la fin de la première vague est
ce que 30% de la population 40 50 60 %
ont été atteints et asymptomatiques pour
nous aider à mieux prévoir ce qui va se
passer
à l'automne une fois qu'on aurait
dépassé le fameux pic de contagion avant
de le ville confinement il va falloir
que les autorités de santé publique est
une bonne idée la proportion de la
population qui a déjà été atteinte par
le col navires us sauf qu'une des
caractéristiques ce que rona virus c'est
qu' environ 80% des personnes infectées
ont soit des symptômes légers à modérés
comme la toux ou de la fièvre ou pas de
symptômes du tout et donc c'est presque
impossible de savoir si on a déjà la
cave de 19 ou sur nul autre chose ou si
on est encore un risque de la voir
à moins d'aller passer un test mais
c'est pas tout le monde tu peux passer
les tests génétiques qui sont offertes
actuellement on n'est pas assez de
matériel pour tester tout le monde il ya
des critères qui ont été déterminés par
les provinces et ça peut être long avant
d'avoir les résultats de la procédure
elle même prend quelques heures mais
avec les délais il ya des personnes qui
peuvent atteindre jusqu'à des jours en
confirmant avant d'avoir leur diagnostic
ce qui est aussi avec les tests
génétiques c'est qu'ils nous donnent
seulement une petite partie du portrait
général comme un instantané qui nous dit
si au moment précis où la personne est
allé passer le test
elle était atteint de lakovic 19 d'où
l'intérêt de développer des tests
rapides et qui permet de savoir sur le
déjà été infectées dans le passé il ya
une équipe québécoise du sur le coup la
chercheuse ump tient en fait partie et
je lui demandais comment ça fonctionne
les castes actuelle les tests rapides
avec des coûts vian dans le nez c'est
pour dépister la présence de virus
actifs
ça c'est ce qu'on doit faire de façon
urgente pour éviter que ces gens là ne
propagent le virus actifs
ce que nous cherchons c'est différent
c'est de savoir qui a été infecté
alors est-ce qu'on a été porteur du
virus parfois même sans s'en rendre
contre lorsqu'on est infecté par un
virus les anticorps pont développe
contre ce virus vont former une immunité
naturelle
on peut l'appeler une immunité acquise
et lorsqu'il y sommes beaucoup de la
population peut-être 50 % 60 70 % ce qui
a eu une immunité acquise alors ces gens
là ne pourront pas être infecté et ne
vendons pas propager le virus dans le
reste de la population qui n'a pas
encore été fait que notre moyen aussi
d'acquérir une immunité
c'est d'être vaccinés sauf qu'en ce
moment il n'existe pas encore de vaccin
contre le virus du colis de 19 jeu
rennais bien dit en principe parce que
tout porte à croire que notre immunité
naturelle va nous empêcher d'être
infecté par la coved 19 une deuxième
fois mais ça va prendre un petit peu de
recul avant de le confirmer
le prototype qu'on développe c'est un
instrument portable la personne à être
testé nous donnerait un échantillon de
sang donc encore peut-être piquer le
doigt on récolte cet échantillon de 5 et
on va l'injecter dans ce petit
instrument tout simplement avec une
future est normal et par une courte
tubulures va se rendre au coeur de
l'instrument la raquette comme un
instrument
c'est ce petit objet qui est un un tri
sme recouvert d'une mince couche d'or
alors sur cette couche d'or
on ne rend immobilisé une partie du
virus donc des protéines du virus
ici la personne dans son sens hollande
score contre le virus
l'anticorps celui sur la surface d'or
qui contient cette protéine et sa venue
un signal qu'on peut observer dans
l'instrument est donc ceci l'observation
de signal se fait au fur et à mesure
qu'on injecte en temps de quelques
minutes qui est très rapide
l'équipe de johanne pelletier qui est
chapeauté par denis boudreau
l'université laval est pas la seule à
développer des thèses des analyses de
sang ce qu'on appelle aussi des tests
sérologiques il ya des labos en europe
en chine puis aux états unis qui ont
aussi développé et mis sur le marché des
tests à bandelettes des tests rapides
un peu comme des tests de grossesse mais
pour détecter des anticorps au corona
virus il ya certains pays qui en ont
acheté un grand volume
mais le hic à m'exciter cela c'est
qu'ils sont pas aussi précis que les
tests génétiques
du canada évalue encore leur efficacité
avant pouvoir en un mot la vie ici
castro développe ne sera pas prêt en
donne quelques semaines nous espérons
avoir des premiers prototypes de
réaction en temps de trois à six mois
le prototype de joël est parfait pour
tester un grand nombre de personnes
parce que c'est un appareil qui est
sophistiqué il coûterait beaucoup plus
cher à produire que des petites
bandelettes
mais il est conçu pour être beaucoup
plus précis il est aussi conçu pour
qu'on puisse la porter dans des endroits
où il ya des personnes qui ont besoin de
savoir s'ils sont immunisés doute pas
une équipe de professionnels de la santé
dans un centre de soins par exemple où
on peut même penser à porter la machine
sur un navire de croisière
on se bat contre un ennemi invisible
bientôt les scientifiques vont avoir
rajouté quelques outils précieux dans
notre attirail de détection pour qu'on
puisse voir comment se défend contre cet
ennemi microscopiques
[Musique]